The answer to this question is 25, unique chromosomes
in the total cellular genome. What I wanted you to
do was look at our nuclear mitochondrial chromosomes, take the
first pair, we don't want the extra copy, right, there
are two copies in this pair. We just going to
count that one as a unique chromosome. It's unique. It's
different from all the other chromosomes. And the same thing
for the second pair. We're not going to count the copy,
this is two. Third, three. Four, all the way till we get to 20, 21, 22.
And our last pair, the 23rd pair, though.
We're going to count each chromosome by itself, because
they're not the same. The X and Y
are different. So, chromosome, there's a 23rd unique one
and a 24th unique one. And then, if
we include the mitochondrial chromosome, that's 25 unique chromosomes.
Remember, you have one extra copy of every
other autosome in your genome at any given
time in the cell and there are many
mitochonria and thus many mitochondrial chromosomes in a
cell at any given moment. But when we
talk about the total cellular genome, how many
unique chromosomes there are There are a total
of 25 when we leave out the extra copies.